our next guest is a friend of the show
Fox Sports a gottlieben I do not know
Doug did you know that Dan was out today
and you were talking to the de Annette's
question I did I did I woke up to
frantic sex from Todd Fritz something
along the lines of these guys can't
carry this show by themselves I'm
reaching out to anybody with a cell
phone that was that was generally the
context of the the text I got that's
pretty much how that went down
yeah we have a lot of topics for you but
let's start with the Clemson quarterback
Kelly Ryan transferring what do you
think of his decision well I understand
when you get beat out you know like look
you go to school you know you wait you
bide your time you get a chance you got
a chance to start for them last year
starts for him this year
and then he gets usurped by a freshman
and you know with the new rule he can he
can actually he can actually redshirt
this year you know just give me a
redshirt year I just don't understand
why you would transfer like college
basketball players do this - why you
transfer you know mid-year yeah just we
just wait I mean how much college
football do we have to see that a guy
gets hit a guy gets hurt a guy has a bad
stretch and like yeah Clemson you got a
chance to win a national championship
I'm not saying you have to stay but stay
through the season and and then you
Trent this idea that the second I get
beat out I'm out deuces because you're
upset with how the situation was handled
I you know this is I'm a transfer I
transferred obviously from other for
other reasons but I was considering
transferring anyway but I I hate this I
got beat out I want to leave right now
sort of thing yes your breath you can
even wait till semester and you can go
if you think it's gonna be the opposite
strategy for Jalen Hertz at Alabama I'll
stay I'll be ready to play when I'm
needed to but I'm probably not playing
the quarterback position in the NFL so
if I play the good soldier at Alabama I
could go into the NFL as a fourth or
fifth round draft choice like Taysom
Hill out of BYU and be a return guy a
running back in all purpose of emergency
quarterback maybe I also think Jalen's
gonna graduate I think this year so if
he waits he can transfer and play right
away whatever he wants to go and yeah he
gets chance maybe to win back
national titles and and also hey what's
the say the - it doesn't - - it doesn't
get hurt because you know it's a
position to which he doesn't run as much
as zero and does but you run around a
bunch back there but I don't you know
look I don't fall kids for transfer I
mean I go somewhere you're gonna play
you know I thought what what Jalen said
it's probably not really true but what
he said after master change again was
amazing right hide you're cheering for
another teammate like I just I've always
started to have that in me like I'll
cheer and I'll be the good soldier but
in my heart of hearts I want to be out
there so I don't I don't fault anybody
for doing go somewhere you're gonna play
win or lose you're going to be happier
that way but the idea of transferring
midseason the second you get beat now
second if somebody makes a change on the
depth chart that's the one that I can't
get down with that's not being it that's
not being a good teammate that's not
what Sports is about in my personal
opinion all right Doug today's poll
question should the NFL change the
roughing the quarterback rule just asked
officials to quietly call it less or
leave the rule as it is so far this
season
what's your answer I mean I think it'd
be answer be listener this this is
obviously a massive net we've seen to
cut massive see changes in the NFL so
this was the the use of the helmet rule
which people wanted the great thing
about this roughing the pastures
nobody's even talking about the use of
the helmet rule I think well what about
what about that controversy but you know
telling your own most career was ended
because of this Aaron Rodgers year last
year was ended because of this man you
know so you have to consider the
alternative and I think if you're erring
on the side of caution so so the
quarterbacks don't get hurt you know I'm
sorry that if defensive players get
called for a penalty and yeah it does
look like they got red jerseys on back
there but fantasy players love it
betters love it everybody who's got the
over should love it and and quarterbacks
are just that important there's that
important an asset you know it's like
we've believed protect presidents long
after anybody's ever going to go after
them because you know they know no one's
going after you know Jimmy Carter but
we're gonna protect him why because he's
an incredible asset he's important to
our country it's what he represents
right same thing
the quarterback they definitely
represent your entire face I got a
greasy Doug if you land with your full
body weight on Jimmy Carter you're in a
heap of trouble these days I don't even
know the rules joining us now on the
damn pants showed think'll what happens
you took Jimmy Carter all the way to the
ground no but you know Jimmy's a man of
principle he would not flop like Ben
Roethlisberger with a little head tap
he's tough guy of all the guys and then
Berger with his phony answer afterwards
about how he feels that defensive
players like dude alright dunk I leave a
Fox Sports joining us the Dan Patrick
show I'm gonna play you a piece of sound
and I bet I know your answer here's
Tiger Woods talking about his all-time
Mount Rushmore of golf my all-time Mount
Rushmore of golf
Jones Nicklaus now Tiger Woods is just
about stating effect they're not an
opinion and no one's really calling him
out on it would you have rather him gone
faux humility and not answered the
fourth one or do you like they said hey
it's me and we all know it I would let
the end listed 3 and then just look at
the camera big smile yeah that would
have been that you know that that that
billion dollar smile hey did you know
this is no poll question did you guys do
this but yesterday the greatest
individual comeback like personal
comeback no we didn't have that play out
in your show we didn't you know kind of
survey radio I'm not you know let's try
that but we talked about a little bit I
mean you know Lance this thing end up
being kind of you know all based upon
performance fancy drugs so he took
himself off the list Agassi came back
from that Agassi came back from math and
a wig you know I guess he had the wig
and mess that was pretty pretty big and
he he landed what you know a beautiful
wife kids Steffi Steffi Graf kids and
and he became the number one player in
the world so I don't know I I guess is
one that comes to mind people say Ben
Hogan because he almost died but like I
don't I don't know much about Ben Hogan
I'm not under disrespect so I don't
realize I think it's a fascinating thing
but I don't what's amazing is
we've gone from him being the punchline
to so many jokes to I don't know anybody
who's Sunday wasn't at least like dude I
can't believe this is really happening
he didn't just be you know I know as a
small field but I mean look at the names
of that field and it leads us we were in
a place in golf floor used to Dan used
to do you know Tiger of the field and I
don't think work you take Tiger over the
field maybe ever but you don't consider
it now where in the past you'd never
even consider him a favor to truly win
with it by the way if you have poll
questions suggestions you can text us in
the morning you know we need help
yeah can you wake up like 4:45 yes a big
time and get on them up a computer yeah
listen I I love listening when you guys
come up with you give me to put it on
the pole the poll questions if I have
one I will fire away done final minute
on the NBA I'm a theory that the Lakers
and the the Warriors are the only teams
that play truly nationally where you got
nothing to do and the Warriors are
playing or Lakers are playing you'll
just tuned in should the Warriors and
Lakers games be bumped up an hour to
embrace the East Coast basketball fan
now that would be 6:30 Pacific 9:30
Eastern Time because a lot of their
games I was looking the TNT TBS schedule
start at 10:30 p.m. Eastern and it's
gonna be hard to get people in Baltimore
New York Washington DC Miami huge NBA
markets to tune in for the first half do
you know how bad that would be at
Staples or Oracle in terms of trying to
get people there if you just you can't
do it you can't get people there I mean
I I mean yeah I don't have to describe
to people in the East Coast what an epic
and complete traffic disaster it is but
if yeah I mean it just it would be
impossible to fill the arena and you
know people would look at look at pac-12
games they try and put them on at 6
o'clock
what about seat fillers its Los Angeles
like like the Oscars just get a bunch of
seat bars until the handsome young
people that would be that would be
amazing
that would be amazing the problem is
everybody's got a job now right you go
back to the you go back to 2010 and that
would have been easy to find and now
it's really hard although although down
in staples you know that's become kind
of a that's a really hot spot now so I'm
sure there's there's plenty of
Millennials that'll that'll sit in
thing they want to be extras you know in
in Stallone's next movie and so they'll
be sitting in there that's actually not
a terrible idea but starting a game at
6:30 and the West Coast is a terrible
idea
now Godwin here what does a copy of Fox
Sports give us the terrible ideas is out
q thank you buddy
talk to you next time Dan six out later
boy that was dug guy Lee to Fox Sports
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]